[Music]
there we go you hate to see it let's
[ __ ] go
because
I don't want to read I don't want to
record more duels after this is over so
I'll probably just take a collection of
duels after 70 what's up Rex yeah
getting hit with them mix-ups nice
I brought a tear to my eye I don't stab
your spleen dude I want Xbox and
Playstation across platform yeah one of
these days men I wish
what [ __ ] mice keeps giving me on that
I'll give that that one's gonna hurt
this'll definitely hurt
Oh why'd I do that
that was stupid as [ __ ] that was dumb
and that was really stupid
Wow Maya I don't know why I did that I
didn't mean to do this side - or the
side dodged I meant to like hit him with
the buckler but that works alright no
problem
round three
I
prepare II know not to do that [ __ ]
again at that little Griffin look all
right Thank You di out of my chow it's
the talk [ __ ] again you see I love my
chat because half the people think I'm
great and a half the people like tear me
down I love it it's a it's like we're
such a divided nation it makes me so
happy
because I never actually know who to
believe anymore [ __ ] here we go again
now go fight Rex thanks for the stream
snipe bro appreciate it
start out with a solid hit
alright glad to see I still don't know
oh I'm bad I said how's dump that was
really stupid
alright I'm getting used to it
I gotta get used to T on D again and how
we place and how this dude place I
believe it County's biondi's biggest
weapon is their voice that's a big fact
him I got a grind I don't know I'm
probably not gonna grind anybody
probably just play blackbriar honestly
I'm not gonna intentionally grind him
like I'm not gonna struggle for like the
Pat like how I did for four days like
with this trying to grind him but I mean
I'll play him I'll play with BB just for
the easy reps I'm just to get that big
gear I think it'd be cool nice how did I
miss all that oh you hate to see these
quick moves and like a cat you come in
my [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] you up maybe sometimes
sometimes you could pass me I had the
feeling a white spam was coming that eon
he's been hitting these lights
constantly so i knew that was gonna be
happening at least one time this man
this man just going deep
I'm so garbage oh please don't off the
map
[ __ ] sorry sir
oh no no no no not the selfie mode dude
that's gonna make them look that's gonna
make you look so bad if I pull the
selfie mode all right whatever it's part
of the game that happens humans are like
cats they both die if you put him in a
wall Jesus okay be on ye oh my god oh my
not off the map okay
I'm standing such an [ __ ] man I can't
fight properly
I'm act that was super close I actually
thought I was going off the map and that
first hit and then yeah okay though
that's a fight
sweet you hate to see it Thank You
temple garden for having so many ledges
dude that guy's so pissed at me alleged
him not once but twice that's like
seeing a rep 70 and only the 70 reps are
on one character holy [ __ ] okay I'm just
gonna fight you down here cuz you're
gonna throw me off the map oh here we go
with this stalemate he lends a stunning
tap it's over
[Music]
Rosi go throw oh my god he actually did
he actually did it to me he actually
threw me in the end of the hole Wow okay
all right so this is how we're gonna be
playing this game all right interesting
that's how we're gonna be playing this
all right
we got this she got played a little bit
better
I had the slide I knew as soon as I got
garb broken I was gonna get thrown in
that River I should have fought him up
top keeps coming for guard breaks I'm
very confused
I should have plot parried punished him
out of interesting okay we're gonna
flight this way so that he has the ledge
so that way if he gar breaks me I'm not
really gonna go anywhere
he's wow he's actually backing up
towards the back of the ledge he really
wants me to go off
[Music]
I'll be fine all right we're good
the guard brakes are gonna be his key
source of damage to off this flight I
know it and and the stomach tap of
course but most of these are gonna be
about the guard break what he's just
back up and guard break me what the [ __ ]
was that
I was impressive I know what to do now I
know what he's doing
caught that one easy I saw that one
coming I knew he was gonna go for it so
I just decide the option selected right
into the heavy not even a light attack
afterwards
uh-oh here comes the crashing chart now
here goes me in the river again why did
they give me this map dude what is this
thing what is the name of this map again
uh tower ruined that bow what a weird
name uh Olson oh I hate this map so much
I've never liked this map okay well
there's still the potential for the
guard break but he can't really like get
too much off of me here nice this is
really bad for me you did it again you
did it again
I'm just gonna keep options like doing
that
and that's over good night gamers
god I hate people that legend dull
sometimes that happens that happens I
also called it a river when it was
literally just a moat but it's okay
[Music]
you